YOUR STARTING GOALTENDE WAS
SKATING, AND IT WAS TAKEN AWAY
BY YAMAMOTO.
MAYBE A TWO ON JOE SACCO -- I
LIKE THE FACT HE DIDN'T TRY TO
FORCE THAT THROUGH THE SPRAWN A.
ON NET BY MARCHAND.
THAT'S ZACH HYMAN HEADED TO SIN.
NUGENT-HOPKINS AND AGAIN THAT
1-0
FOR STUART SKINNER, HE'S
EXPECTING THIS SHOT.
HE'S GOT ALL THE TIME IN THEARK.
HIGH IN THE AIR, NUGENT-HOPKINS
ACROSS.
ONE-TIMER.
TRIES TO JUMP OUT OF THE WAY,
BUT AGAIN YOU L L, HIS FIRST GOF
SKINNER, AND UNDER
PAIN.
DRAISAITL OPEN.
NEUTRAL ZONE WRIST TIPPETT.
NAME LEINEN A SHOT.
THAT WAS BLOCKED IN FRONT --.
DROP PASS.
PULJUJARVI LOADS AND FIRES.
SAVE MADE AND THE REBOUND
AND EDMONTON DOES GET ON THE
BOARD.
DRAISAITL'S
WANTED TO HEAR HIM SING --
YEAH -- BECAUSE HE WAS THE LIFE
OF THE PARTY.
HARD AND PULJUJARVI UP ICE., THT
OPPORTUNITY DOWN THE RIGHT-HAND
SIDE.
PULJUJARVI RIPS KASSIAN.
BOUNCING PUCK.
FOEGELE'S SHOT DENIED.VER ULLMA-
HEAVY WRISTER -- AND McAVOYP HIH
LIKE THAT INTO THE FACE OF
FOEGELE.
HERE'S THE FINISH!
>> Answer: THAT IS 23 FOR
DRAISAITL AND WE
ELEVATED, IN TIGHT, UP OVER TOP
OF ULLMARK F
HERE'S FOEGELE DUCKING INSIDE.
GOING TO TRY TO THROW THE PUCK
ACROSSLMARK HAS PLAYED WELL.
HERE'S MARCHAND.
A STOP.
SKINNENE WITH 5½ ON THE CLOCK.
>> Louie: NO QUESTION IT'S
BE CLIFTON.
REBOUND IN FRONT.
WHAT A SAVE, SCORES!
3-2 BOSTON!
STANDING RIGHT IN FRONT OF